Les amis bien venues dans cette deuxième vidéo à la Virtual Room juste ici.
Natoo tu peut te baisser?
Elle présente hyper bien.
Y'a un muscle, regardez!
Regardezregardez, c'est fini son corps de lâche là [...]
[M:] Aller serre, serre, serre, regardez. Oui!!
Ouiiiiiiii ! *rires*
: tu vas à la salle, faut dire la vérité, explique aux gens.
Il aura beau pousser et tout en interne c'est beau mais ce sera jamais impressionnant.
Nan jamais personne fera *wah!*
Attendez y'a quand même une bosse...
Est-ce que je peut faire mon intro?
Abricot dans ma bouche !!
*Carlito lance l'abricot*
Souvenez vous, on s'était rendu dans un monde parallèle, ou plutôt fictif dans un casque VR on avait kiffer de ouf! C’était génial ou pas?
Personne m'avait écouter j'avais tout le temps raison mais...
C'est vrai mec, vraiment les gars, elle a vraiment raison parce que j'ai vu le montage, [...]
[...] j'ai fait "c'est un truc de ouf comment on l’écoute pas
(ep.1):} Mettez la tête dans le placard, mettez la tête dans le placard !
(ep.1):} Oh p*tin on peut mettre le casque [...]  (ep.1):} Mettez la tête dans le placard !!
Natoo, calme toi.
Aujourd’hui on est de retour! pourquoi? Parce que la Mission 2 viens de sortir [...]  Ouiiiii !!
Apparemment la difficulté est  [...] (Augmentée)
*Rire* [...] par rapport a la première mission
C'est à dire qu'on va devoir vraiment faire travailler nos méninge [...]
[...] Et on va devoir écouter Natoo les gars, vraiment je vous jure la dernière fois elle était excellente.
Apres peut-être que cette fois je serai pas inspiré donc...
D'accord donc n'écoutez pas Natoo du coup pendant cette vidéo
J'peut dire de chose ? [...]  oui ? [...] on essaie de pas se marcher dessus cette fois [...]  oui
[...] Et deuxièmement si j'ai mis un bonnet c'est pas pour contrer ma calvitie [...]  bah non [...]  *Un peu quand même.
Ah oui d'accord!
Les amis, je vous prévient juste d'un petit truc aujourd’hui on n'veut pas vous spoil toute la mission, ce qui gâcherait le plaisir des gens si vous veniez ici faire l’expérience.
Je rappel que vous pouvez le faire virtuellement aussi si vous voulez. [...]
[...] Vous êtes prévenus alors ne vous en faites pas il y aura quand même un [...] rouge dans la vidéo. Bien évidement on va finir, on va réusir a s'enfuir je vous rappel que c'est une escape game [...]
[...] Donc le but c'est de s'enfuir
*aboiements*  Ta geu** kitty!
Excuse moi, je parle mal.  Mais il est au téléphone
: ...déjà avec le titre, les gens ont compris.
Il s'en bat les coui***
: Les amis ça fait plaisir de vous retrouver [...]
[...] Je vous rappel qu'on est chronométré on a pas tout le temps qu'on veut
Regardez il y a un truc qui arrive là bas [...]  Qu'est ce que c'est ? [...] ah il y a un truc qui arrive [...]  Ça va m’écraser les gars vraiment, non c'est bon.
*Oohh*
Alors on a des boutons devans nous et il y a ça qui arrive [...]
[...] Qu'est ce qu'on doit faire les mecs?
Natoo! Natoo! Qu'est ce que je fait comme danse là regarde!
Mais ferme la, y'a un truc qui arrive!
C'EST LA MACARENA!!
Ok les gars, je suis chef d'équipe vous 'm'équipez!' [...]
[...] vous 'm'écoutez' pardon! [...]
[...] On a deux conteneurs, un à gauche un à droite. [...]
Est-ce que tout le monde à un tableau devant lui avec [...]
[...] les mêmes petits boutons? (C et N): OUAIS!
Alors à mon avis c'est comme au début, il va falloir juste trouver comment prendre nos équipements.
Il y a un code sur le truc. Vous voyez tous le code?
Ouais
Donc à mon avis, il faut juste chacun trouver son code.
Qu'es ce que vous avez en bas de votre écran tactile ?
Bien moi j'ai le signe oméga.
Moi j'ai une sorte de E mais à l'envers.
Ah moi j'ai un triangle.
Ahhhhh!! M: Moi j'ai autre chose.
Tu as quoi ?  J'ai une lettre mais je sais pas ce que c'est.
OK.
*Rires de squeezie*
On est très lent
WOOOOOA, Vous pouvez ouvrir sur le coté les gars!! [...]
[...] Sur le coté il y a des trucs à ouvrir !
P**ain les débilos.  Oui mais on est tellement con!
Y'a des Bananes !!! QUI VEUT DES BANANES ?!??
Moi je veux bien une banane bio, Lances!
Tiens !
Ah! Mince...
Hé les gars c'est tellement frustrant d'avoir un truc à bouffer et de pas pouvoir le bouffer.
Chers amis, j'ai un écran avec 4 symboles et 4 codes.
Les gars il y a notre selfie là, regardez !
C'est bien parce que personne ne m'a écouté! Vous êtes incroyables!!
Pardon, pardon, je t'écoute. Arrête de faire tes crises d’ego Raph!
On est pas là pour s'embrouiller
J'ai un IPad avec 4 codes et 4 symboles.
: Et bien alors donne moi le symbole oméga s'il te plais le code.
C'est un O sans le...
: Tu le coupe en bas juste.
20, 16.  Ouiii, ça a marché!
Donne moi ton symbole toi Natoo
Moi c'est un E inversé alors je sais pas (Sigma)
OK 76, 46
McFly? M: Mon symbole c'est, euuh
une sorte de... Comme un petit pont (Pi)
OK "41" "68"
Oh ça a ouvert, Bravo !
Ouiiii! M: Comment je la met l'armure?
Mon outfit of the death.
Yes ! Il y a une porte en bas, regardez !
Ah bien ouej.  Ah on peu faire un ping-pong!
Carl Carl!  Carlito tu veux jouer au ping-pong toi et moi ?
Nan, moi je joue avec McFly c'est...
Nan c'est mon ami c'est mon ami ! toi tu te tais
Mais non mais McFly.  Aiiie Je me suis pris un mur. [...]
*rire* [...] *J'ai pris le karma
C'est bon j'ai trouver la carte, il faut la [...]
mettre ici dans le meuble IKEA.
Aller, tout le monde met la carte les amis!
On a mis une heure sur la première étape qui est un tutoriel.  J'ai la statuette du 5eme élément.
Vous ne vous écoutez pas !
Il y a une statuette du 5ème élément
Mais c'est moi qui l'ai dit !  Met la carte David!
Je suis persuadé qu'il faut la rentrer tout les 4 en même temps!
Comme dans le 5eme élément, est-ce que vous êtes prêt?
Nan faut juste que tu, Nan faut que tu la mette dans le bon sens juste Raph
C'est bon !  J'ai déjà insérer moi. *Rire de squeezie*
OK, du coup écoutez les gars ! la mission [...]
[...] n'est pas terminé il y a un truc à faire
*Rires*  Attends attends
Hé regardez tous Raph, c'est hyper drôle
Elle est tombée ta carte ? *Rires*
*Rires*
Au lieu de me dire il y a un sens, [...]
c'est comme quand t'es à table [...]
[...] Ok? [...]
[...] Y'a un truc que tu veux prendre et que tu dit [...]
[...] "Tu peux me donner ça" Ce n'est pas, 'un' vrais [...]
[...] 'Une' vrais phrase.
Mais c'est juste l'intro du jeu et on est là depuis une demi heure.
*Euphorie générale*
WOWOWO il se passe des trucs WOW
(Narrateur du jeu): L'humanité à besoin de vous
Ah bah oui tiens
(Narrateur du jeu): Une flotte extra-terrestres a envahi la terre et [...]
[...] s'emplois à la détruire.  Ah, ça va être fou!
(Narrateur du jeu): Les extra-terrestres ont envoyé des balises [...]
[...] à travers la galaxie.
(Narrateur du jeu): Ils nous espionnent depuis plusieurs siècles.. Nous.....
Oh, y'a Lola à coté de moi :D
(Narrateur du jeu): Voici votre mission: vous devriez remonter le temps aux époques où les balise étaient encore opérationnelles
(Narrateur du jeu): Trouvez-les, téléchargez les données Aliens qu'elles contiennent et renvoyez ces données vers notre époque
(Narrateur du jeu): Bonne chance équipe Oméga!
OK, on donne tous les gars, on donne tous!
-Distorsion temporelle-
Ah ça, j'adoore ça!
Il faut se trouver un cris d'équipe!
Wacomda
Oh y'a un joli masque
On dois récolté l’énergie de la balise, c'est ça? (Ouai)
Eh regardez ma gueule!
Ah génial!
Nous sommes à l'époque des Incas, Natoo va nous raconter un peu cette époque.
Alors les Incas font un très bon chocolat!
*BLANC TRÈS GÊNANT*
Yes, on est chronométré, il va falloir avancer. *Rires* Alors..
Wow, mais tu fait quoi toi??
(Natoo hurlant dans un boucan): Regardez, y'a des lampe-torche!
*Chamaillerie entre McFly et Squeezie*
[*Chamaillerie entre McFly et Squeezie*
où Carlito essaye de parler.]
*Chamaillerie entre McFly et Squeezie*
Eh, regardez ce que j'ai fait en attendant bande de naze!
Regardez...  Oh!  Oh, pas mal!
Ok, tout le monde fait comme Natoo, tout le monde fait comme Natoo.
J'suis désolé, je ne comprends rien, je n'entends rien. Qu'est-ce que tu a fait Natoo?
Alors, j'ai trouvé une lampe torche dans une des mains des statues, [...]
[...] et ensuite je l'ai mise dans le feu pour l'allumer.
Raph, il n'a pas de feu, Nat, il fait que tu lui donne la torche avec le feu que tu as.
Attendez.  Oui!  Merci Nat!
Et derrière toi, c'est quoi par terre?
Ecoutez-moi! Raph normalement tu a une fontaine la ou tu es non?  OH!
Yes! *Boucan général*
Regardez, regardez le circuit!
Oh oui, c'est de l'essence, c'est le l'essence!
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
Eh les gars...  AAAHH !
OK, laisser moi dire, laisser moi dire: y'a une boule qui est tombé en réaction à ce qu'on a fait.
Oh oui, oui, oui, oui, oui...  Y'a quoi sur la boule?
Ah bah mettez la boule dans le.. dans le truc où y'a une boule qui va, tout simplement.
C'est une boule de bowling.
Il faut.. Il faut...  OH ÇA DESCEND, ÇA DESCEND QUAND ON MET LA BOULE DEDANS!
Ça me rappelle Tom Rider.
C'est une bonne situation, statue...  OUIIIII !!
Le soleil fut, et le soleil fut.
Oh regardez, y'a un truc qui va se passer!
peut être qu'il y a ma gloire qui va revenir...
Regardez là bas, c'est sublime.
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
*Ouais Collectif*
Les gars, c'est le meilleur jeu de la vie, les gars!
Je vais revenir avec toute ma famille
Écoutez, écoutez!
(Narrateur du jeu): Vous avez trouvé la sortie.
-Distorsion temporelle-
Mais c'était fou!
Eh mais elle a été trop bien cette épreuve!
: Salut, tu vas bien toi?  Tu vas bien? (M et C): comment ça va?
Est-ce que tu a prévenu Sylvain pour la Crémaillère?  Mon dieu, oublié.
Elle est où "Lele", elle n'est  pas la "Lele"?
"Lele" elle est, je n'sais pas, je n'là vois pas.
J'ai peur de lui mettre un coup sans faire exprès
Eh les gars, on vous dérange là?
Ah pardon, ouai déso, nan parce qu'il n'a pas invité Sylvain a la Crémaillère.
Oh regardez, regardez, regardez, Signal detection. [...]
[...] Quand j'ai mi ma main regardez, regardez ce qu'il se passe!!
Qu'est-ce qui se passe, Qu'est-ce qui se passe?  WOOOOOW!
J'suis un p*tain de ouf.
Je le prend
WAAAAAAAAAAA !
P*tain, c'est dingue!
Et  alors, faut faire quoi là?
Attend! [...]
[...] Mais laisse moi la boule toi! MAIS ARRÊTEZ!
Oh tu l'a!
Voilà, téléchargement, moi je télécharge au moins!
Bien joué BG
Ah c'est l’énergie qu'il faut récupéré, on a notre première bouboule d’énergie, [...]
[...] alors il en reste plus que 3, BRAVO!!
Mais j'ai rien fait, je ne comprend rien!
(Les autres): 1720
Attendez! Je ne met pas le dernier chiffre. prenez un temps pour regarder le paysage qui est incroyable!
Oui S: C'est vrai que c'est magnifique!
La différence entre le décor et la gueule que vous avez est tellement dingue!
Alors tu critique pas mon visage toi, ça commence à bien faire toi.
Depuis tout à l'heure tu me parle mal toi! J'en ai marre de toi
Viens chez moi, viens chez moi,-viens chez moi!!
arrêtez de vous [...] *Bruit de verre qui se casse* [...] disputer!
*Rires*
Sa tête, elle est cassé en deux.
Pardon David, je ne voulais pas te faire mal, pour de vrai :3
*Rires*
-Distorsion temporelle-
Oh c'est trop beau!  Ohhh
Regardez a vos pied, il y a un câble, [...]
[...] je pense qu'il faut tous qu'on relie les câbles qui sont à nos pied les gars
: D'accord.  Ouais bien sûr.
On peut pas les prendre
Ahh, on peut pas, il manque des morceaux de câble. Est-ce que quelqu'un peut nous dérouler son câble?
*Natoo qui rigole à sa blague pas drôle*
Ces câbles, ils sont pétés. Quelqu'un a pété les câbles ou quoi?
Oh là là...  Oh là là là là là là...
Écoutez-moi! dans ce tonneaux... {S: Ah les gars, il y a de la poudre, il faut juste relier.
Ahh d'ac...
Mais c'est ma phrase, j'voulais la dire...
Bahh fallait être plus rapide, c'est tout.
Vous reliez les deux cables, OK? C'est bon pour tout le monde?
On dirait une énorme merde.
OK les gars, je vais tout faire péter!
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
What the f*ck men?
Oh mais les gars j'ai...  Oh y'a un train les gars, regardez!!
Y'A UN TRAIN!!
*Natoo Qui flippe*
OK les gars, vous avez un chariot là, prenez ce qu'il y a dedans!
Vous pétez le cadenas avec la pioche
Moi c'est déjà fait. Hop la!
Est-ce que tu peux me passer la pioche, mais nan, mais p*tain, mais c'est hyper égoïste.
*Natoo qui rit*
Natoo, est-ce que tu peux nous aider...  TA G*EULE
Arrête, arrête, regarde...
J'en ai marre vous m'écoutez jamais, vous m'écoutez jamaaiis!!
Écoutez-moi je respecte les animaux,
MAIS VENEZ, ON DÉFONCE LES AIGLES
Mais nan, j'ai pas envie de participer à cette tuerie moi, perso.
Nan, c'est pas gentil.
Nan, mais naann!! [...]
[...] Mais c'est horrible!
Arrêtez, arrêtez!
nannn, je suis pas biennn....
Ceci est dans le cadre d'un jeu.
(Tout le monde): Il arrive, il arrive!
Attention reculez les gars, reculez. Je vous rappelle qu'un un train peut en caché un autre.
Ah y'a un pied de biche de votre côté. Normalement, vous pouvez le prendre pour ouvrir la caisse.
Alors attends.
Y'a un pied de biche sur le train et normalement vous pouvez le prendre.
Ah ouai bien ouaij.
Les gars, je n'vois pas le pied de biche que vous voulez parler. Haha, c'est trop bien!
Mais moi j'en ai pas...
Ah t'as pas de pied de biche Nat?
Nan.  Moi non plus.
: Ah y'a que moi qui a un pied de biche?
Nan moi aussi
Vas-y, fait péter le pied de biche frère!
Envois le pied de biche [...]
[...] Mais..? [...]  Pardon, excuse-moi. [...] Enfoiré!
Il va se reformer, regardes bien!
tiens!
Ensuite vous allez avoir un marteau, les amis, et vous tapez sur le petit truc en bois qui se trouve sur le train.
Et une fois que la planche est pétée, vous pourrez tourner la roue, alors vous faite tournez la roue.
J'ai hâte de voir ce plan où je tape nul part.
Oh, punaise..!
*Satisfaction général*
je voulais m'appuyer sur le truc du train mais j'ai oublié que, nan, c'était pas possible.
Eh, à la Youtube Money
Bah, pour vos 4 millions en faite, juste...
Ouai voila c'est ça que je voulait dire
Les amis, par contre là j'suis angoissé, j'suis seul dans l'espace, et vous?
Je suis dans un sas de sécurité.  Pareil moi, un sas.
Vous avez un petite trappe que vous pouvez ouvrir?
Nan mais David, où est-tu?
Ah oui, y'a une trappe les gars, au milieu.
Il me faudrait une sorte de croix à mettre dans ce truc, [...]
[...] donc, faudrait que l'on s'échange des formes alors.
Moi j'ai un cylindre qui ressemble a une grosse pile.
Ouais, je l'ai aussi.
Bah, à mon avis il faut le placé...
Ah! Ça y est, je l'ai rentré, super! [...]
[...] Ah, j'en ai une qui flotte en face de moi!
Les gars, est-ce qu'on peut passer en second degrés et juste kiffer! Regardez, c'est fou, c'est fou! Voilà!
OHH!! [...]  Frère, ça va? [...] Mais attendez, attendez, attendez, attendez, attendez, attendez!
Depuis le début, vous vous voyez tous, [...]  Oui [...] vous me voyez pas et tout le monde s'en bas les c*******
*Rire de McFly*
Mais c'est un truc de ouf! Mais je [...]
[...] *Inaudibles*...putain!
Lucas, qu'est-ce qu'il fait? Arrêtez, Lucas il boude les gars...
Nan mais continuez, c'est pas grave, continuez...
Nan mais mec, attends, boudes pas! Ça va wesh!
Écoute-moi, je vais prendre une salade césar à midi et je te donnerais juste la sauce
Lucas, c'est toi qui me paye mon repas ce midi!
Dans ce cas, je me lève, les mecs! C'est trop cool p*tain.
Ahh voilà!
Qui a eu son Bac avec mention ici?
Moi!
Moi, mention assez bien juste.
Oh regardez, regardez! Raph va faire un truc, regardez!
Regardez bien ce qu'il se passe quand on grandit à Bois-Colombes avec une mère de qualité [...]
[...] Et voilààà.
*Rires*
David, est-ce que tu peux me filer le truc qui a là, juste devant toi qui vole là.
Carl écoutes-moi. J'ai besoin de ce que tu a en face de toi, ce truc là.
Oui ça s'slot en face de toi là.
J'ai réussi à mettre l'objet dans l’espèce de trappe moi.
Il faut que vous m'en envoyez 2 autres, il m'en manque 2 autres!
Qui aurait besoin de ces "gwings-nuks"? On va appeler ça...
Moi j'ai besoin d'un "gwings-nuks".
On va appeler ça les "gwings-nuks"
C'est pour Natoo! Passes!
Sa fait franchement 10 minutes que je vous dis qu'il faut m'envoyer ces pièces et vous m'envoyez c*ier
Mais parce quee...
On t'envoie pas c*ier, on envoie les pièces actuellement.
Yes! Je l'ai!
Vas-y Nat. Mets les dedans et je pense que le truc va s'ouvrir et j'aurais une vue super belle!
Ah renvoie, renvoie!
Voilà, c'est propre ça les gars, c'est propre...
C'est bon!
j'ai peut-être des auréoles, mais c'est de la virtuelle auréoles évidemment.
je pue mais c'est pour de faux!
Bravo les gars!
Ouai stylé!
Moi j’arrête de parler parce que j'ai peur d'être trop brillant.
Regardez-moi par ici! [...] (Les autres): Ouai! [...] là vous avez des trucs à monter. Mettez tous sur le vert.
Ah oui, tu a raison p*tain
Ah, bien Ouaij!
Moi j'en laisse 1 rouge.
Nan, bah nan, du coup ça va bloquer tout le monde. 'fin...
Tout le monde a mi tous sur le vert?
Moi j'ai tous mi... Ah non, j'ai tous mi sur le rouge... *rire (De Natoo bien sûr)*
Ah Natoo, mais c'est terrible ça! Enfin...  Pardon...
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
Mec, c'est l'ISS, c'est génial!
La vue de ouff!!
Waaaaaaaaaaa! M: Les gars, je veux trop y être!
(Narrateur du jeu): Félicitation, le sas est ouvert.
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
La vie est plus nulle ce que jeu! Waaw, l'espace, le bonheur!!
Regardez, j'ai un casque de cosmonaute et pas vous!
Oh naannnn [...]
[...] Ils vont pouvoir aller dans l'espace
Regardez, coucou!
Ah, il en a un aussi!
Eh mais tu a un tuyau mais il n'est pas brancher ton tuyau. AH!
*Rires de vache (De Natoo)*
Nan mais nan, rends-moi mon casque. Toi t'abuses toi!
Je t'es volé ton casque.
Excusez-moi, comme je suis le plus poète et le plus mature et contemplatif, observez ce qu'il se passe
J'aimerais prendre un moment pour que l'on s'allonge tous et qu'on médite un petit peu.
Oui! Est-ce que on peut chanter "Un peu plus près des étoiles"
♪ UN PEU PLUS PRÈS DES ÉTOILES ♫
♪ AU JARDIN DE LUMIÈRE ET D'ARGENT ♫
Flinguez moi tout de suite, tuez moi!
Tuez moi!
Les amis ce moment est magnifique et j'aimerais vous dire à quelle point c'est un plaisir de tourner avec vous depuis...ces deux années.
Vous êtes mon rayon de soleil!
Raph tu peux venir vers moi, juste s'il te plaît, vite fait en restant allongé.
J'voulais te dire un truc Mais...  J'aimerais que l'on s'allonge ensemble toi et moi, je t'aime Raph ♥
Merci pour...
Je t'aime..., je  t'aime de tout mon cœur. ♥
*Rires*
Oh nan, ils sont en train de copuler!!
Nan, mais nan, mais nan!!
Ils copulent, il a dézippé sa combinaison, Je l'ai vu!!
Quelqu'un a du sopalin?
*Oh-oh Collectif*
Qu'est-ce que c'est..? [...]
[...] Ça va sur moi! AHH!
Qu'est-ce qui fait? Tuez-le!
AHHH...!!
What the f*ck?
Oh les gars, y'a un bras, il nous a laissé des caisses. Les mecs, vous avez des armes, c'est parti!
Attendez mais...
Comment on fait pour mettre les recharges dedans?
J'arrive pas à la mettre!
: Comment on fait les recharges??
J'arrive pas à mettre la recharge!
Alors vous les mettez en dessous, là, en dessous!
Je suis nuul!
Oh, j'ai une arme de malade moi!
Mais je...Je n'arrive pas à mettre ma cartouche!
Les gars, on l'a chopé avec l'ISS
J'ai vraiment été inutile pendant cette partie!
-Distorsion temporelle-
Oh la vache!
Vous êtes en sueur?
Je suis en sueur des yeux juste.
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
5 Minutes, 5 minutes!
(Narrateur du jeu):  Les données Aliens que vous avez collectées ont permis à nos ingénieurs de construire [...]
[...] une arme qu'on espère assez puissante pour détruire l'envahisseur.
On va zigouiller de l'Alien
WTF! S: Whaaaat?
OH des drones !
Eh, c'est SpaceX
Oh là là, oh là là, j'ai la boule,- j'ai la boule! [...]
[...] Qu'est-ce que je fait de ma boule?
Mettez vos boules dans les drones, mettez vos boules dans les drones!!
Faut la lancer?
Si c'est bon je l'ai lancée, ça marche!
: C'est bon!
Ok qu'est-ce qui se passe maintenant?
Oh p*tain! Oh les gars je contrôle le drone!
Ah ouai, ouai, ouai! C: Quoi?!
Mais comment t'as fait ça, mec?
Là, vous bougez ce qu'il y a dans le cube [...]
[...] Ça va être un bordel! [...]
[...] Quand vous prenez la boule et que vous l'avanciez, le drone avance,- quand vous leviez la boule le drone se lève,- Ect...
J'ai perdu mon drone p*tain
Ahhh... Faut pas les perdre les gars!
Ah je l'ai perdu, c'est fini mon gars!
Ah, ça y est! Je l'ais! OUuUuUUh!!
Ça c'est une Nat, ça! Vas-y, avances Nat. Il faut que tu ailles sur la plateforme  qui est en face de toi, là bas, dans le vide!
Et le mien, il est où, les gars?
P*tain, vous avez perdu vos drones!
P*tain, les gars, on a paumé nos drones, c'est chaud!
Ils ont perdu leur drone!
Oh les deux gros c**!
McFly et Carlito ont détruit l'humanité!
Souscrivez un abonnement!
Et ont les met où alors?
Ils faut les amener là bas, regardez! Regardez, je suis en train d'y aller, regardez...
Ahh!
Natoo, viens jouer, viens jouer Nat!
(Narrateur du jeu): ...dans 3, 2, [...]  Aller vas-y, n*quer lui la gueule [...] 1, 0.
*WwOoOOoOOw Collectif*
Yes, Yes!!
YES!
(Narrateur du jeu): ...de la flotte Alien est détruit
Yeaahh!!
Yes!
C'est comme la foire du trône mais en mieux!
*Rire de Squeezie*
En tout cas, n’hésitez pas a venir, c'est une expérience incroyable. Et surtout vous ressortez avec cette tête [...]
[...] et ça mon gars, ça fait de très belles photos d'Insta!
Bonsoir...
*Rires de Squeezie de McFly*
Mec j'suis ému, j'ai l'impression qu'on est partis en vacances
*Joie de Vivre*
Attends,-tends,-tends, il manque quelqu'un là.
Cette expérience quand même...! C'est [...]
[...] c'est un délire!
C'est fou ce que ça a fait!
(S et C): C'est incroyable
Oui mais moi, c'est dans le jeu,- c'est dans le jeu que ça ma fait ça!
Les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas a l'aimer si elle vous a plu [...]
[...] Merci d'avoir regarder et n'hésitez pas a vivre l'expérience en vrai. Franchement, c'est chant-mé [...]
[...] on est pas payer pour faire cette vidéo ou quoi... Mais juste je trouve ça trop bien, trop innovant!
Ça défonce!  C'est génial! [...]
[...] En attendant, abonnez-vous a la chaîne de tous ces gens y compris la sienne sur Instagram... [...]
[...] et merci d'avoir regarder, au revoir et encore merci a vous, je vous aime!
Attendez, je vais leur faire vivre l’expérience en vrai!
*Outro*